this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development um yeah so this is billon
I'd like to get us started on our
webinar topic today haptics designing
for touch but to sort of frame this I
want to I'm going to talk a little bit
about design at Stanford design you know
is a big word in at Stanford design is a
really really large part of what we do
we have ket of course have the sort of
internationally well-known d.school
which is our Graduate Institute of
Design but for over 50 years there's
been what we call the design group or
the design division inside the engineer
in the School of Engineering and this
has been where a dedicated team of
researchers professors and students have
been looking at the really big and
interesting issues in design we have a
product design discipline we have a
major called smart products products
that have both mechanical electronic
sensors motors actuators in them we do
we have a lot of research in robotics
and this webinar is actually a part of a
series sponsored by the innovation
masterclass on design and design
thinking our method of problem solving
that puts sort of the human at the
center of the problem you can look up on
the web we have them all up on the SCPD
website that Professor Chris Gerdes did
I talked about autonomous vehicles and
as I'm thinking in the car of the future
Stanford strangely enough is one of the
Centers of automotive research in the
u.s. sort of this kind of stuff because
cars are so computer driven and and
there's more software in most vehicles
now than there are in most homes the
center of research for the car industry
has sort of shifted to Silicon Valley
and Chris and his lab are building cars
to drive around campus by themselves
it's very spooky then professor sherri
shepherd also did a thing we do a lot of
studying at the Sanford design research
on how designers actually design what is
the thought process that designers you
to design and Sherry's been studying
that she did a webinar I call design
thinking and peak performance how do you
how do you get peak performance out of
innovation teams professor painting
Banerjee also I think as part of my CV
are things that a talk on design has a
strategic tool using design thinking to
form strategies for companies nonprofits
and others but today we're going to talk
it with this a brand new topic and it's
a brand new webinar we have a new lab at
Stanford professor Allison Okumura has
joined Stanford just recently and the
charm lab is where Allison and her PhD
students are researching haptics which
is I'll let her explain more in more
detail but its tactics is designing it
were around the sense of touch our since
but one of the more powerful senses of
the human body is its ability to
perceive the environment to the sense of
touch and even though all these topics
cars robots you know products and other
and other things are very very different
subject matter we're all united in our
approach to problem solving which we
call design thinking it's a human
centered approach for if we put humans
at the center of the design problem and
if you think about it there's nothing
more human than our sense of touch we
rely on it you know every second of
every day as part of our way of
perceiving ourselves as humans in the
world Allison has done a study of this
important topic and she's going to take
us through some really interesting
information about haptics particularly
as it as it with regard to new forms of
medical medical devices and surgical
devices that are in the industry now and
really part of can the forefront of
what's going on in haptics so I'll turn
it over to Allison great thank you very
much for the introduction bill I'm
really delighted to be here today and
I'm glad that so many people are
interested in learning about the field
of haptics so by the way if you're
interested in learning more about our
research this will be a fairly
high-level talk but the details are at
the charm lab
website as Stacey mentioned charm stands
for collaborative haptics and robotics
and medicine and our website is charmed
stanford.edu if you'd like to learn more
we also have a number of outreach
programs we're really interested in
getting these ideas out into the
community today I'm going to talk about
haptics designing for touch and I want
to start by having you think about the
various senses that we have there
hearing sight smell taste and touch are
probably the five senses that everyone
learns about in school and in thinking
about their their value one question you
could ask is of course which which sense
is the most valuable to you that might
be a little bit abstract so another way
to ask the question is in addition you'd
said is in addition to saying which
sense is most valuable to you you could
also say which sense is the one that you
would relinquish last and so I see
people are already filling out the poll
which is terrific I'll give you a few
more seconds to let me know what you
think all right and what's turning out
is the response that I overwhelmingly
get that sight is the most important
sense and there's no wrong answer here
of course but what I would like to do
tell you a little bit more about touch
that might change some of your minds see
there are a few people there who are
interested in touch is the most valuable
sense so moving on let's actually think
a little bit raising a question of which
sense would you give up last you could
remote what would life be like without
touch and like a lot of work in science
one way to understand a particular
modality of sensing or a way that humans
work is to look at patients who have
some kind of deficit which is actually
caused them to lose their ability to do
something and there's a gentleman from
Great Britain named Ian Waterman who
lost his sense of touch and there's a
great BBC documentary about him if
anyone's interested in looking at more
details
now even Waterman lost his sense of
touch and as a consequence had trouble
with a lot more than actually just
perceiving the world because I obviously
touches about perception but it's
actually also a lot about movement and
our ability to interact with the world
and make a physical chain on the world
and so Ian Waterman lost his sense of
touch from his neck down and for many
many years was unable to walk to move to
feed himself to do many of the
activities of daily living because of
the loss of the sense of touch and he
actually is one of the few people in the
world who had this terrible problem and
who actually did manage to regain his
ability to move and he did that through
compensating with the sense of sight
however any slight distraction he might
look at a pretty girl get distracted
he'd actually fall down because he
wasn't using his vision to compensate
for his sense of touch so let's think
more about the sense of touch and and
try to emphasize why it's so important
so this is a concept from from Daniel
Wolff port a well-known neuroscientist
who who asked the question fundamentally
why do we have brains so we have trees
plants that don't have brains and we
have animals including people who do
have brains and what is the big
difference between these organisms well
the tree doesn't have to move around
actively in kind of real-time in its
environment whereas a cat does and so
the ability to move is such an essential
part of what makes us active physical
beings that the thought is that that is
the reason for having having a brain is
to allow movement and neuroscientists
also look to sort of evolutionary
evidence and examples from nature to
inspire us and how we come up with these
theories so I just put up a picture of
the sea squirt which is an organism that
actually swims around with a rudimentary
kind of brain for much of its life and
then
and at some point in its life it anchors
itself to a rock and essentially becomes
a plant never to move again and at that
point it eats its brain as they say so
it's sort of a amusing example of how it
seems like you don't really need your
brain unless you're actually moving
about in the environment so what does
all this need to move interact with the
environment have to do with the sense of
touch well it allows us to actually the
sense of touch actually is what allows
us to make these movements so let me
give you a more formal definition now of
the word haptics it really means
anything having to do with the sense of
touch and it's it's not a made-up word
at you can think of haptics is to touch
as optics is to vision and it comes from
a Greek root which means to grasp or to
touch and so the field of haptics has
anything to do with touch my specialty
is on building robotic devices and
virtual environments and interfaces that
allow us to feel the sense of touch in
kind of an artificial way there are also
many researchers who say come from the
psychology or neuroscience perspective
and want to understand the biology of
how haptics works and it's very
complicated as you can imagine because
there's so many different components of
it on 1/2 on the left of your slide you
see the cutaneous aspects and cutaneous
means having to do with the skin so
temperature textures slip vibration and
local force these are all things that
you feel in your skin which are
important part of the sense of touch so
if you just take your fingers right now
and run it over the table in front of
you um you can probably feel some
texture and its information special
mechanoreceptors which are basically
little sensors embedded in your skin
which provide you with cutaneous haptic
information and on the other side of the
slide you see that kinesthesia
information which is more about large
scale forces and movements and so
another exercise you can do right now is
you can hold up your hands and touch
your fingers together over your head
without looking at them
and you may have missed the first time
you did it you may have recovered and
I've been able to get your fingertips
together the second time but this is
being done you can ask yourself how is
it that I'm making this movement without
actually looking at it visually and the
idea is you're using your kinesthesia
which has a lot to do with the sense of
haptics it's knowing the location or
configuration of your body in space and
that's very important for being able to
make movements around the environment
and it requires you to know and
understand through feeling through the
sense of touch what is the motion of
your limbs and so you can feel them what
muscles forces you can feel the stretch
of your skin and all of this gives rise
to knowing where your body is in space
so it's not just about feeling forces or
properties of the environment but it's
also about understanding yourself in
addition you do want to perceive things
about the environment like compliance or
stiffness for example and the
combination of the large scale more
forces and motion information with the
zucchini aslope skin information all
work together with the human motor
control system to do two main things one
of which is to coordinate movement and
the other is to enable perception so you
can think of coordinating movement as
all these things that are needed to
allow you to do the activities of daily
living walk around pick up a drink
etc and perception to both help you
perform those movements but also just to
learn about the environment and these
are all very important things for what
make us human so let me put this idea of
haptic sin into the context of design
thinking and what this slide shows is a
series of elements that go into the
design thinking process and if you've
been to our webinars before you attend
our innovation master series classes you
you will see this theme arise again and
again and let's start with the beginning
you know the first step is is
emphasizing and so for emphasizing
in in almost any field but especially in
haptic design you have to think about
how am I going to provide value to the
user and so in haptics I need to
understand as a researcher and as a
designer when and where does the sense
of touch actually provide that value and
I'll be talking more later about my work
in the field of medical robotics in
which the user sometimes it's the
patient say in a rehabilitation scenario
and and sometimes the user is a
clinician like a surgeon and it requires
us to really understand what these
patients and clinicians need so we spend
time in the operating room we watch
surgical procedures we work as physical
therapists we talk to patients and we
try to become really embedded in the
environments in which our systems are
going to be used and that empathy is a
totally necessary first step for
performing a haptic design the next is
to actually define you know define the
problem and note what what it is that
needs to be solved and empathy actually
is of course the first step to even
being able to create that problem
definition and for haptics I think one
of the most fundamental aspects is that
what makes it challenging and what makes
it an interesting problem for me to
solve from a research perspective is is
that how this has to be interactive and
that is an incredible challenge because
you have to let a user interact with a
system or environment in whatever way
they want to and you have to provide a
haptic response a sense of touch that's
appropriate for that interaction and you
know you've probably seen people do all
kinds of strange things with technology
and computers or their cell phones
whatever it is that they're interacting
with and and the haptic feedback has to
respond appropriately and so for me
that's kind of the problem definition of
haptics have you let people do what they
want to do with a system and you give
them a sense of touch which is
appropriate forever whatever that kind
of interaction might be the next phase
is ideation
and coming up with what is the what is
the way in which you might solve that
the problem or challenge that says
brought to bear and for me looking at
haptics is is great for questioning
assumptions so many of you respond that
that site is the most important sense
and so many of our interfaces with
computers or mobile devices is is
through sight and so if you want as or
open your mind to the possibility of new
designs and then this K Pathak's you
have to question your assumptions about
what is the most appropriate way to
interact with the system what is the
best kind of feedback to give to a user
and that's a question of assumptions
it's a powerful tool for ideation the
next phase is prototyping so you have to
build and don't expect that the first
thing that you build is going to be the
final the final product and and building
I mean that in the broadest sense of the
word sometimes for me as a mechanical
engineer with a with an engineering
background prototyping off often means
physically building something but it can
also mean programming something it can
mean for creating a storyboard for how a
process or procedure might commence and
so prototyping in all of its forms is an
essential part of the design process and
of course for for half dicks every time
say one of my graduate students comes to
me and says I have a new haptic device
or a new design or a new program that
I've created the first thing I say is I
need to feel it and we try to interact
with the systems that we make as quickly
as possible and I think one way to think
about the field of haptic this sub field
of robotics and one of the parts about
haptic said I think is it makes it a
really fun area of Robotics is that it
is inherently interactive you have to
seal it in order to know that what
you've designed is working correctly so
that prototyping saves is absolutely
important and then finally there's
testing and I shouldn't even say finally
because obviously
this is an ongoing process it leaps back
and you would prototype over and over
again but going to testing in my lab we
do both informal and formal view their
studies and sometimes they're very very
quantitative in nature where we will
have say two types of haptic feedback we
would like to test and we will have one
population of users a novice surgeons
use one device another group use a
different device and we see which one
that's better and we try to really
become a quantitative not only about
users performance but their their
feedback qualitative feedback as well
about what they liked and what they
found useful and sometimes we also do
user studies which follow a kind of we
call it an open response paradigm where
we might tell a user to draw what they
feel or just tell us about what they
perceive through a particular type of
interface and so these types of tests
run the gamut but it's always the case
that after these tests we learned a lot
we go back we run through all of these
steps and put the definition ideation
prototyping and testing over and over
again throughout the design and research
process and so hopefully this gives you
an idea of how our haptic research fits
into sort of Design Thinking paradigm
that that really pervades a lot of the
work that we do here at Stanford so let
me give a couple of examples before I go
into the details of how we have applied
optics and medical robotics I'd like to
give some examples of haptic set that
you might be familiar with
since there are haptic devices and many
commercial products now so the first one
is entertainment which is really the big
one in terms of commercial success so
far so many of you have probably played
with the Nintendo Wii and this is just
one example there are many other
products that incorporate haptics and if
you've played with a Nintendo Wii and
you you take your four remote control
that you hold in your hand and you play
Wii tennis as you swing your tennis
racket to hit the ball you'll feel a
little vibration a little bit
kind of feeling white when you when you
hit the ball and that is a form of
haptic feedback you feel this vibration
you feel these these changes in force
which let you know that that you hit the
ball now when you combine that with
sound and vision overall it provides an
extremely compelling experience I'll
also note that that sort of vibration
feedback that's sort of the poor man
Patrick's feedback there's actually a
lot more that we that we can do in
addition to just feeling vibrations we
can use with different types of devices
for feedback that actually generates the
force in the shape of really pushing on
and feeling three-dimensional objects
and this has been used in the next
application example I want to mention
which is education and broadly this has
been used at education at all levels so
in my labs at Stanford informally in
Johns Hopkins we've used simple low-cost
haptic devices the designs of which
we've made public and feel free to
contact me if you're interested in these
these low cost haptic devices students
can use to hook them up and program them
by a computer smell just like you would
a small robot but you can use them to
generate a different haptic sensations
that might be able to communicate to a
student what it means for something to
be a spring or have a stiffness for
example that's a little bit more for
engineering education on the other
picture shows a surgical simulator from
a company called immersion where I used
to work part time and this company that
time made surgical simulators where you
could actually feel like you were doing
surgery so in the picture you have a
person that's holding a type of
endoscopic instrument like a
laparoscopic instrument that could be
used for minimally invasive surgery
there's motors inside the box that apply
forces to the tool that the user is
holding and he's seen a graphical
display of what it would look like to
actually be performing surgery and the
important part here is that the motors
are applying forces to the user so he
feels like he's actually manipulating
tissues and just like flight simulators
are now required for for pilots to
practice on before they apply Commercial
Airplanes
more and more these types of surgical
simulators are being used for surgeons
and trainees to practice on before they
perform on actual patients and naturally
the the realism and the utility of these
devices are being very carefully studied
and developed to be very sophisticated
so that when someone practices in these
virtual environments it really feels and
looks and sometimes even sounds like
doing real surgery lasts more generally
they're just all sorts of computer
human-computer interfaces that use
haptics so one example is there any
lucky people out there that drive a BMW
or maybe Tuesday's Alexis that have a
haptic interface what's shown here on
the left is a haptic knob which as you
turn the knob it can be made to have
different haptic sensations different
types of force feedback to the hand
so maybe the knobs sometimes could feel
very smooth or another time it can be
reprogrammed to feel like a series of
clicks and the idea is that the single
knob the single interface could be used
to control a wide variety of the
different types of controls on the car
whether it's temperature or radio etc
and this is now using a wide variety of
cars cellphones are another example
right now the type of haptic feedback
that people get from phones is
relatively rudimentary this kind of poor
man's vibration feedback but you can
make the vibration feel different
depending on who's calling just like you
can change your ringtones people have
even programmed cellphones to have
vibrations that correspond to their
ringtone so you can feel can't touch
this through vibrations and then a more
I guess a commercial example but is
being used more on the development side
is that Boeing has developed haptic
interfaces that allow them to navigate
the very
in size of an airplane during the design
process to allow a user to kind of
bounce around in the virtual environment
that represents their airplane and see
can I actually you know fit a part in a
desired location or not and sometimes
having a human operator interact with
this virtual environment to see if you
can fit a part in or make a repair is
actually much more efficient in terms of
time and computation than just trying to
do this sort of analysis by computation
alone so people are using haptic devices
of human-computer interfaces for a wide
variety of applications so let's move on
to robotics and medicine a little bit
and I'm going to spend much of the rest
of the talk giving a particular example
of how we've used tactics and medicine
but I thought first I should motivate a
little bit about why are we even talking
about robotics and haptics and medicine
in the first place
it's like you are just familiar with
robots from what you see in movies you
think of them as humanoid potentially
dangerous and scary but there are a lot
of good aspects of robotics that make
them very applicable in medicine and let
me go through some of those points now
so first robots can be more accurate and
precise than people that is they can be
more repeatable they could do the same
thing over and over and they can do it
in an untiring fashion as long as
they're plugged into the wall or have
enough batteries also surgical robots
for example can be smaller or larger
than people as is needed for access so
what's pictured on the right here is a
surgeon's hand and also a Da Vinci
Surgical Instrument this comes from a
company called Intuitive Surgical which
makes a commercial surgical robot which
I'll tell you a little bit more about
earlier but the idea is that this small
instrument which is only about a
centimeter in length near the gripper as
compared to ten times that size with a
human hand can go into the body and have
similar dexterity to that of the human
hand and it's controlled by a human
operator actually so it's not an
autonomous robot that is doing this
based on its own intelligence but it
extends the reach and accuracy and the
dexterity of the surgeon in a way that
is
minimally invasive to the patient and
just to look at the other side of the
coin you this is an example of a robot
that's smaller than the human operator
you can also have robots that are much
larger than the human operator so for
example a physical therapists often
develop orthopedic problems back
problems from lifting heavy patients
trying to help them say relearn how to
walk after a stroke and so a large robot
which is of course designed to be safe
and works in concert with the physical
therapist could be used to provide the
weight support for a patient and then
help the physical therapist do their job
better all of this sometimes
necessitates that the robot be remotely
operated so just because of changes in
scale like I mentioned a human operator
can remotely control the robot and
sometimes it's also necessary just for
reasons of safety so some of the very
first teleoperated robots were designed
for cleaning up and manipulating nuclear
materials and of course you would like
to keep humans away from such dangerous
sites and so if you could use a remote
robotic device that could be very useful
I'll also point out in the next bullet
that robots are connected to computers
which gives them access to information
and this is important because it's not
just about the mechanical devices hello
I'm a mechanical engineer constrained by
training and and I love the devices but
what really makes robots so powerful is
that they have access to information
which in a clinical setting could be
preoperative scans about the patient and
information from other types of sensors
and maybe talk about say blood ox and ox
finish up oxygenation and all of this
information can be used to help control
the robot but I will point out that
robots are not able to operate
autonomously in all highly complex in
certain environments yet I say we're
getting very close bill mentioned the
great work of a professor Chris Curti is
doing autonomous cars and obviously
driving around in an
environment is an extremely complex
environment but I would argue not yet as
complex as the inside of a human body
with its deformation and very immediate
safety issues in terms of the fact that
there's physical interaction with a
patient and so there is an innate need
for human interaction in robotic devices
that are performing medical procedures
and this is where haptics comes in I'll
just note in one other slide about the
potential impact of medical robotics and
and where I think using robots in
clinical applications can really help us
and that's outlined here so if you you
know look along the diagonal line at the
end of this triangle you could say that
a lot of treatments today are
qualitatively and quantitatively limited
by human abilities so let's say you have
an expert surgeon who's the only surgeon
in the world that can do particular
procedure well it has a very high level
of challenge that a human might be able
to meet but very very few patients could
actually be treated
conversely sometimes there are some
procedures which have less level of
challenge and more procedures patients
could be treated and the idea is that
with various technologies including
robotics you could have more clinicians
perform even more difficult and even new
procedures that we haven't even imagined
yet whether it's surgery or
rehabilitation so we want to expand both
the number of patients access to
healthcare and treatment as well as the
level of challenge and the types of
treatments that we can provide and to
give a picture of how this might work
I'm going to go through just a little
flow chart of sort of a big vision for
how robots can be used in medicine so we
really start out with two things one one
is the the patient him or herself as
well as what we call an atlas which is a
record information about lots of other
patients and what was done to them who
had similar deficits similar
difficulties
all this information goes into what we
call a preoperative planning stage where
you model the patient often based on
images say for MRI or CT or x-ray and
you use computer programs to help you
plan what is the best way to treat this
patient and again the information coming
into this block is not just about the
patient him or herself but also lots of
information about what happened to other
patients and that's very important
so after this planning stage you
actually go into an intra operative
stage well I'm using kind of surgery
here as an example there's also
applications here for rehabilitation and
other medical medical applications so in
this intraoperative stage you may update
the model you may update the plan and
the robotics comes in here in terms of
having a physical real-time computer
assistance and these robots can take
many many forms and this one we have our
surgeon in green who's sort of
cooperatively manipulating a robotic
device as a patient's being imaged in
order to perform some kind of procedure
and that sort of c-shape thing is a is a
C arm x-ray which we should have more
and more of these imagers inside the
operating room used in real-time and
then finally there's a post-operative
stage that afterwards you assess what
was actually done to the patient was the
procedure successful and all this
information go into the database that
can inform that atlas so the next time
you have a patient with a similar
problem or if you have to retreat this
same patient for some reason that you
really have a good record and
understanding of what was done and the
great thing about having a robotic
device and all these sensors in this
loop is that you have a real
quantitative information about what
actually occurred now I'll note that
while this sort of procedure isn't
currently always being applied in
medicine that it's not a completely new
idea so for people that have
manufacturing experience you might
actually recognize these blocks the
first block being like computer-aided
design the second like computer assisted
manufacturing and the last being
total quality management and so if
you're familiar with these concepts in
manufacturing it's really applying these
same ideas to trying to make medicine
better of course I'm not implying that
patients or products or anything like
that but the idea being that you want
their outcome to be the very best
possible and you should bring to bear
all the tools that you can is is highly
motivating for medical researchers and
technology developers so given that
somewhat long-winded introduction to
medical robotics and and why I think
it's useful and important and why we
should consider it
I want to talk now more specifically
about haptic feedback and robot-assisted
surgery and just give you one example of
a research project that we've done that
incorporates tactics that might help you
know put a exact implementation in your
head when you really think about how we
use design thinking in our research so
we have interacted very closely with a
company called Intuitive Surgical which
makes a commercially available surgical
robot called The Da Vinci Surgical
System and this is a teleoperated robot
where the surgeon you see in the green
scrubs to the surgeon console and
basically manipulates what amounts to a
fancy seven degree of joystick it moves
in seven directions basically you can
think of it as X Y Z a pitch roll and
then gripper and then the patient side
robot which does look a little big and
scary is actually going into the patient
through very very small thin instruments
you have a robot behind these
instruments is quite large but what's
actually going to patient are very small
tools and so this teleoperated robot is
allowing the surgeon to have the kind of
dexterity inside the patient with
minimal access and minimal invasiveness
which i mentioned earlier as one of the
great advantages of using robotics and
surgery and despite the fact that it's
teleoperation the surgeon is still in
the same room as a patient
we still need all of the same medical
personnel there in order to provide the
anesthesia to
check from all the patient's vitals
cetera but the idea is that the robot
can make the surgery less invasive for
the patient and much more accurate so I
think I'm going to actually skip over a
couple of these slides just to get to
the specifics of our research topic so
that we can make sure we have time for
questions and you'll be able to look at
all the slides later if you like so
let's look at for a system like The Da
Vinci Surgical robot the commercial
robot while wildly successful and it's
being used in hundreds of thousands of
surgical procedures every year it
currently does not have haptic feedback
to the user that is when the surgeon is
Telly offering the remote robot he does
not feel what is happening at the
patient side she could the surgeon she
could see what's happening at the remote
side so in the picture shown here you
can see an instrument that's poking at
an artificial tissue but the surgeon
wouldn't normally feel this information
and so we did a study where we modified
a surgical robot and we looked at what
would happen if you provided haptic
feedback to the user and we also wanted
to understand does it really have to be
haptic that is does it really have to be
forces applied to the surgeons hands or
could it be some other modalities like
an extra visual display and so what you
also see on the image in the lower left
is a little bar graph which currently is
kind of halfway up and it's colored
green and as a surgeon pushed down on
that on that environment the bar can go
up or down depend on how much force is
applied so with these different types of
feedback modalities we actually have
four conditions that we can test the
first one in red which is labeled hhg is
haptic plus graphical so Hassocks means
we program the system so the user gets
force feedback to their hands letting
them know what is the force being
applied in the environment and the
graphical part is this visual display H
is haptic only G is just that graphical
only adjust that visual bar graph which
has been overlaid on the image the
dispersion sees
and s means no force-feedback so the
surgeon would still get the normal video
but wouldn't feel forces through their
hands I wouldn't see this extra bar
graph and it turns out that if you take
an experienced robotic surgeon this is
someone who has done many many surgeries
already in patients with the robot we
find that in detecting a hard lump
inside tissue the error is greatly
decreased when you have haptic feedback
so this is the kind of quantitative
testing that we would like to do in
order to ensure that the things that we
design are going to be appropriate to be
brought into the clinic and so you can
see the H G in the H which are the two
conditions where the user felt real for
feedback to the hands have much less
error than the graphical or no force
feedback and those thin lines those
vertical bars which are the thin lines
are errors because of the variability of
the different users and you can also see
the variability is much larger when the
users don't have forced feedback and so
this really motivates the idea that well
so maybe graphical information can't
really replace haptic information in a
task like this it really does need to be
forced feedback okay
so overall using this kind of technology
our goal is to improve surgery and just
to bring this back to the design
thinking approach I'll note that for a
project like this we need to emphasize
with surgeons and some cases with with
patients have to stay in a surgery
example the patient's is usually under
anesthesia and where they're not really
using the system but in other
applications we work on like prosthetics
or rehabilitation the patients are
involved we need to define a problem can
we really make a surgeon better with
haptic feedback and doing what what what
different conditions do we want to test
in this case our idea was that we should
test both visual displays as well as
haptic display part of the reason being
that a graphical display would actually
be cheaper to implement in a surgical
robot and applying force feedback but by
prototyping the system and doing a test
we could actually determine which is the
best feedback modality for a situation
like this
so and this is a this is one example of
a single research study but this one
that I just showed was done several
years ago and it is a research topic
that we just revisit over and over again
we look at how do you give haptic
feedback in different ways and so it's
not like we go once through this process
and say that we're done
we definitely revisit and look at every
year we're coming up with new projects
on how do you incorporate haptics into
environments like this so with that I
want to thank you for listening to my
talk let's take a couple of questions
here I think um you can look at the
slide on the master series in the next
page we have to send you some
information on that but we got a couple
of questions I want to get to one
question came in from from one of the
participants talking about medical
robotics and the things that are already
there in clinical testing and things
that are already out in in deployment
and the question was there have been
very few cases of cardiac surgery done
in with using medical robotics and the
question is this is this because the
devices are really expensive and
difficult to learn or is this skepticism
by cardiac surgeons and and in general
could you comment
Allisyn on how these kinds of really
radical new surgical techniques using
robot assistants are being adopted or
think thought about by the by the
medical establishment that's a really
great great question because actually
the company Intuitive Surgical that
design is da Vinci Surgical robot their
actual original goal was cardiac surgery
to do the very complex procedures
including a lot of suturing etc during
heart surgery and and that you're right
that it hasn't actually been adopted
that much in in cardiac the place where
the robot has been really successful has
actually been in prostate surgery to
remove
uh sections of the prostate due to
cancer and that so people from a company
actually sort of joke that they aimed at
the heart and hit the groin but that's
actually the the way that the robot was
developed was originally for cardiac
procedures and I don't believe that any
lack of sex success of the robot has
anything to do with surgeons sort of
deploying to turn a blind eye towards
this new technology pretty much every
surgeon I've talked to some have healthy
skepticism but nevertheless are really
interested in any technology that will
help improve patient care so it's
actually every experience I've had with
with surgeons of all types and
interventional radiologists as well has
been extremely positive in terms of just
wanting to make sure that we're doing
the right thing for patients but as to
why I think that it hasn't been a
successful in cardiac surgery I think is
because of the increased complexity of
cardiac procedures if you say want to do
a triple bypass the amount of time that
takes in the number of operating
personnel operating room personnel that
are required is just extremely heavy
load and and because of the complexity
of the procedure it has made it much
harder to incorporate wrought Roboto in
the operating room and I do think that
the lack of haptic feedback is part of
that and say it's still an ongoing
hypothesis that has to be tested and
fully worked out but because of the
delicacy of the movements and
manipulations that are being done in
cardiac surgery having haptic feedback
really should improve procedures of that
nature it's not to say that prostate
surgery is an easy thing but there's a
little less kind of criticalness to the
delicacy of the manipulation that occurs
in that case great we haven't ever maybe
one more question
this is not in the medical field but
just in a general area of input devices
you know we've sort of been stuck with
keyboards in mice for as long as you
know anyone can remember here's a
question are there any portable devices
or other input devices that use haptic
interfaces that
and substitute for keyboards
touchscreens or other you know kind of
the common interaction interfaces that
we have for computing devices what's on
the horizon yeah that's that's a really
great question so you know with even
with haptic devices there has to be sort
of sensing of the human input and then
the haptics is the feedback that then
returns to the user and input devices
these days are so limiting you know even
on something of some of the nice
touchscreen interfaces
maybe you move from one finger to two
finger and multi-touch but that's still
pretty limiting and so you know these
days for example Microsoft came out a
couple years ago with the Kinect which
tracks whole body motion and more
devices like that are being designed
actually just for the hands and so
gesture inputs are definitely being used
more and more but they also create a lot
of challenges in terms of how you
actually then give Hasek feedback to the
user because you may be now moving your
hands and space and not directly
touching something and so that's
actually leading researchers to develop
more wearable haptic devices things that
you might have sewn into your clothes
and sensors even sewn into your clothes
things that things that are just
wearable and become part of your
environment without explicitly saying ok
we're going to make this into an
interface